the streets of China's major cities have
been rocked by protests highlighting
deep-seated frustration with the
country's zero covered policy after
years of lockdown a few voices have even
been heard calling for leader see Jim
ping to step down
the state's powerful security machine
remains in control for now but the
frustration that inspired the process is
real and now Mr C faces a dilemma
should he ease restrictions and
potentially risk more than half a
million deaths from covid-19 or continue
the lockdowns and put his economy under
further strain and social order at risk
Xi Jinping should have done something
different a year ago he should have got
ready for this moment now the real worry
is that they're going to pay a terrible
price
Xi Jinping has built an extraordinary
security machine that means that this or
that political protest probably doesn't
frighten him that much he can Crush
those he's already rounding people up
but the fact that it speaks to a real
anger that is so much larger and so
widespread that is why I think we see
them now scrambling to change course
without a plan zero covered is not just
the same policies we have in say Britain
or America but a bit stricter it has an
incredibly sort of ambitious core which
is every single positive case of covered
should be found and put into quarantine
as soon as possible
Xi Jinping faces a really tough dilemma
because the quickest way to end the
anger is to lift the lockdowns and get
back to normal but he still has a virus
raging around China and if he lifts too
quickly or without the right
preparations then he could have a giant
exit wave and huge numbers of deaths
there are scenarios and models where you
get 680 700 a million people could die
China had a pretty good vaccine campaign
uh earlier but this year they've hardly
vaccinated at all they haven't really
addressed that big problem of the old
not getting vaccinated covered is not
just a health problem in China Xi
Jinping has made this into a central
argument that the Communist Party loves
the people of China and is keeping them
safe and doesn't want them to die and
that is the big difference with decadent
selfish democracies in places like
America where a million people have died
because of this pandemic and so because
he's made it into a totem of the
benevolence and wisdom of the Communist
Party to have a failure now is more than
a public Health disaster it's a major
political humiliation he needs to make
this less about politics and allow the
experts and the scientists to dictate
the policy which has not been happening
because it was all about Xi Jinping as
the commander-in-chief of a people's war
against covet no the government of the
world is trying to fight kovid like a
war it's not a war and if you keep us up
they're going to be defeated
I'm David Rennie Beijing bureau chief
for more of our coverage of the pandemic
in China you can click on the link or
please subscribe thank you for watching